This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇妙的现代世界中展现出的心理坚韧、体能以及复原力的构建。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。这就是数字 2.百分比，可在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾历史》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾历史”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？您正在收听由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的“艰难前行”。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在其他任何地方进行这些对话真的都不安全，但您正在与一位知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcast 或您获取播客的任何地方收听“艰难前行”。 2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定测试做了两次手脚，对吗？我做过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, it's Gemma.
迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。嘿，我是杰玛。
And I have something really special to share with you. I'm hosting my first ever virtual live video podcast. Not a pre-recorded episode, not a highlight. real, but a real time face-to-face moment where we get to connect, laugh, and kind of just reflect together, no matter where you are in the world. Plus, I'm hosting a VIP after-party for my inner circle where I will be answering your questions and getting to talk to you guys even more. It's happening August 12th at 7pm Pacific Time or August 13th at 12pm if you live in my hometown of Sydney. You can grab your ticket now at pave.live. I cannot wait to see you there.
我有一些非常特别的事情要与大家分享。我将主持我的第一个虚拟现场视频播客。不是预先录制的剧集，也不是精彩集锦。真实的，而是实时的面对面时刻，无论您身在世界何处，我们都可以联系、大笑并一起反思。另外，我将为我的核心圈子举办一个 VIP 派对，在那里我将回答您的问题并与你们进行更多交谈。活动将于太平洋时间 8 月 12 日晚上 7 点或如果您住在我的家乡悉尼，则于 8 月 13 日中午 12 点举行。您现在可以在 pave.live 上抢票。我已经迫不及待地想在那里见到你了。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back through the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are on the world. You guys know the deal. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we get into it, I just want to let you know that this episode does touch on disordered eating, weight loss and discussions of food and calories. I know that this can be a sensitive topic for some people, so please just consider whether you are ready for an episode like this, whether it is something
大家好，欢迎回到《二十几岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十几岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好，欢迎回到节目，欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众，无论你在世界的哪个角落。你们都知道规矩。很高兴你能来到这里，回来观看另一集，当然我们会剖析二十几岁的心理。在深入探讨之前，我只想让大家知道，这一集确实涉及饮食失调、减肥以及对食物和卡路里的讨论。我知道这对于某些人来说可能是一个敏感的话题，所以请考虑一下您是否准备好观看这样的节目，是否是
you need to hear today. It will still be here in a week. week, in a month, in a year when you are ready to hear it. But until then, please take care of yourself and we will have links to services and resources below. But hello everybody. Today, we are serving up a topic that touches literally everyone every single day, often without us truly grasping its real impact. How the very food we eat directly shapes our mood, mental clarity, and overall emotional well-being. Now, this is something that I've been very interested in personally for a while, but I've always kind of held off on doing an episode about it because I'm not a nutritionist. I'm also not a doctor. So I wanted to make sure that we got some good researchers in and that we
你今天需要听。它仍会在这里呆上一周。一周，一个月，一年，当你准备好倾听的时候。但在此之前，请照顾好自己，我们将在下方提供服务和资源的链接。但是大家好。今天，我们正在探讨一个几乎每天都触及每个人的话题，而往往没有真正掌握它的真正影响。我们吃的食物如何直接塑造我们的情绪、精神清晰度和整体情绪健康。现在，这是我个人一段时间以来一直非常感兴趣的事情，但我一直有点搁置制作关于它的剧集，因为我不是营养师。我也不是医生。所以我希望确保我们请到了一些优秀的 研究人员，并且我们
had all the essential research together because it is kind of a sensitive topic and one that people can very easily become misinformed about. But from a personal level, this is a personal level. This is something that I endlessly fascinated about. I have spent so much time tracking, considering, thinking about what foods make my brain feel sharper, lighter, more energized, and what makes me feel bad in my body, what scrambles my brain, what makes my health feel worse. I have never been one to track calories. I probably never will. But I do track how my mood response. to what I eat, whether I feel foggy, irritable, or alive and present. And turns out there's a lot, and I mean a lot of science behind these reactions that is so
把所有重要的研究放在一起，因为它是一个有点敏感的话题，而且很容易让人产生误解。但从个人的角度来看，这是一个个人的角度。这是让我着迷的事情。我花了很多时间追踪、考虑、思考哪些食物能让我的大脑感觉更敏锐、更轻盈、更有活力，是什么让我感觉身体不好，是什么让我头脑混乱，是什么让我的健康感觉更糟。我从来都不是一个追踪卡路里的人。我可能永远不会。但我确实追踪我的情绪反应。我吃什么，无论是感到精神迷糊、易怒，还是充满活力的当下。事实证明，这些反应背后有很多科学依据，我的意思是很多科学
fascinating to dive into. The truth is, your brain is not a solo act like we typically think that it is. It's actually in constant conversation with another major organ, your gut. I think a lot of the time we ignore the psychological role of food. We say it's just fuel or it's something to restrict for weight loss or it all comes down to calorie content. But your breakfast, your lunch, your dinner choices subtly impact your daily emotional landscape. It also impacts your resilience to stress.
潜入其中令人着迷。事实是，你的大脑并不是我们通常认为的那种独奏行为。事实上，它一直在与另一个主要器官（你的肠道）进行持续的对话。我认为很多时候我们忽略了食物的心理作用。我们说这只是燃料，或者是为了减肥而限制的东西，或者这一切都归结为卡路里含量。但你的早餐、午餐、晚餐选择会微妙地影响你的日常情绪格局。它还会影响您对压力的抵抗力。
It may even impact your risk of anxiety and depression. This is all coming down to a very emerging field called nutritional psychiatry, which basically says that when we examine our food, we learn more about how our brain operates the way that it does. So in today's episode, we are going to unpack what exactly this gut brain access is, why your microbiome matters way more than you think it probably does, why it's important to take care of it, how to take care of it, and of course, how certain foods on your plate might influence your mood in ways that you've never even noticed. We're also going to explore how mood affects food,
它甚至可能会影响您患焦虑症和抑郁症的风险。这一切都归结为一个名为营养精神病学的新兴领域，该领域基本上说，当我们检查食物时，我们会更多地了解大脑运作的方式。因此，在今天的节目中，我们将剖析这个肠道大脑通道到底是什么，为什么你的微生物群比你想象的要重要得多，为什么照顾它很重要，如何照顾它，当然，你盘子里的某些食物如何以你从未注意到的方式影响你的情绪。我们还将探讨情绪如何影响食物，
so things like comfort food, how community and culture play a role in what foods we choose to consume, and the dangers of villainizing certain food. Labelling certain foods is either good or bad and why people may think that that represents clean eating, healthy eating a way to properly fuel your body, but can actually have the opposite effect, how we talk about food, the labels we give it, impacts our psychology, just as much as the nutritional content of the food. So there is so much to break down, so much to acknowledge in
因此，诸如安慰食物、社区和文化如何在选择消费什么食物中发挥作用，以及将某些食物妖魔化的危险。将某些食物贴上好或坏的标签，为什么人们可能认为这代表清洁饮食、健康饮食、正确为身体补充燃料的方法，但实际上可能会产生相反的效果，我们如何谈论食物，我们给它贴上的标签，会影响我们的心理，就像食物的营养成分一样。所以有太多东西需要打破，有太多东西需要承认
this episode. And I think we clocked over like 50 research papers contributing to this, to this one episode. So you're going to get a lot of information all and one go, which is of course always our intention. So without further ado, let's get into how food affects our mood. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
这一集。我想我们记录了大约 50 篇贡献给这一集的forschungs-papiers。因此，您将一次性获得大量信息，这当然一直是我们的初衷。废话不多说，让我们来看看食物是如何影响我们的情绪的。和我们呆在一起。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我打破了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们真的认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 上的 TWO%，或您获取播客的任何地方。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，您可以在“回顾历史”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick a here. unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个这里。剖析到底发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的合作，大谈 80 年代的快克。需要明确的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意一整天都在谈论快克，但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看到有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for Black. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade
现在艾滋病也在讨论之中，所以。然后你完成了那个句子。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。人。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾历史”。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难前行》，我是您的主持人、您最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的经验
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch
我在心理健康领域的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这件东西，而我们还在追逐它，并且我们不知道什么时候做得够了，因为人们在看记分牌
life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person
生活变成了关于输赢史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现在地球上做一个好人很重要，还是你因为害怕而成为一个好人，因为兄弟，这是两种不同的意图，绝对是，这是两个不同的信任级别，我希望你真正成为一个好人
Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯（Keir Gaines），在我的新播客《艰难前行》（Learn the Hardway）中就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开您的免费 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索“艰难前行”并立即收听。 2023 年，前单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了父亲身份丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。由此开始了长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。埃伦，你对这个特定测试做了两次手脚，对吗？我做过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是爱情陷阱。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so if we are going to talk about the psychology of food, we actually have to move away from the brain for a second and talk about another essential organ, that being the gut. Let's waste no time here. We're going to jump straight into this thing
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着赛季的继续，新闻劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。女士们先生们，美利哥县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart 广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。好吧，如果我们打算讨论食物的心理学，我们实际上必须暂时离开大脑，谈谈另一个必不可少的器官，即肠道。这里不要浪费时间。我们将直接跳进这个东西
called the gut brain axis. So the truth is, is that we often think about our brain as the sole command center for our thoughts and our emotions. It's kind of been how we've been taught to see it. The truth is your brain and your gut and constant communication. The gut brain access is basically this intricate super highway that is constantly filled with information traveling in both directions between your digestive system and your brain. And it involves several key players which we're going to break down. The first is the vagus nerve. This is the longest cranial nerve. It runs directly from your brainstem, so at the bottom of your skull, down to your abdomen. You've probably seen people talking about this more and more recently.
被称为肠脑轴。所以事实是，我们经常把大脑当作我们思想和情绪的唯一指挥中心。这可以说是我们被教导看待它的方式。事实是，你的大脑和肠道在不断沟通。肠脑通路基本上是这个错综复杂的超级高速公路，里面不断充斥着在你的消化系统和大脑之间双向传输的信息。它涉及几个关键角色，我们将在下面进行分解。第一个是迷走神经。这是最长的脑神经。它直接从你的大脑干（也就是你的头骨底部）一直延伸到你的腹部。你可能最近越来越多地看到人们在谈论这件事。
There's been a few very famous books on it in recent years and how learning more about your vagus nerve can calm your anxiety, calm stress. But beyond that, it's basically just a direct high-speed information pipeline that transmit signals about gut sensations, inflammation, even the microbiome state, which in turn does end up influencing stress response and emotional regulation. For instance, researchers just recently suggested and found that disruptions in vagal tone, basically that's like the activity in the vagus nerve, have been implicated in anxiety and depression because it has such a critical role in physiological and psychological arousal and also in our well-being. It also plays a really important role in the parasympathetic nervous system, which is basically the part of our nervous system, which helps to regulate stress throughout the body.
近年来有几本非常著名的书探讨了它，以及如何更多地了解迷走神经可以平静你的焦虑、平静压力。但除此之外，它基本上只是一个直接的高速信息管道，传输有关肠道感觉、炎症甚至微生物群状态的信号，这反过来最终会影响压力反应和情绪调节。例如，研究人员最近提出并发现，迷走神经张力的破坏（基本上就像迷走神经中的活动）与焦虑和抑郁有关，因为它在生理和心理觉醒以及我们的幸福感中发挥着如此关键的作用。它在副交感神经系统中也发挥着非常重要的作用，副交感神经系统基本上是我们神经系统的一部分，有助于调节全身的压力。
Stress and our alarm response. So if something with this nerve isn't working, it can make it harder to bring ourselves down from a state of alarm, from a state of arousal or stress, meaning that our anxiety and fear response lasts longer. The next key component of the gut brain axis are neurotransmitters, the chemical messengers that basically allow for the cells in our body to communicate with each other. You probably learn about neurotransmitters in science class, specifically their role in the brain, but nobody probably told you where they actually come from. It was like, they exist and then this is their function. You know, for me, that was the extent of my curriculum.
压力和我们的警报反应。因此，如果这条神经出现问题，就会使我们更难从警报状态、觉醒状态或压力状态中恢复过来，这意味着我们的焦虑和恐惧反应持续时间更长。肠脑轴的下一个关键组成部分是神经递质，即基本上允许我们体内的细胞相互交流的化学信使。你可能在科学课上了解过神经递质，特别是在大脑中的作用，但可能没有人告诉你它们实际上来自哪里。就像，它们存在，然后这就是它们的功能。你知道，对我来说，这就是我的课程的极限。
even when I studied psychology at university. Like, I don't think anyone ever said in a lecture where neurotransmitters came from. They were just kind of existing and we just examined what they did. But one guess where neurotransmitters are made. Your gut. Your gut produces a significant amount of the very neurotransmitters that regulate your mood, specifically around 95% of the body's serotonin. Basically, our feel good hormone.
甚至我在大学学心理学的时候，好像也没有人在讲座里提过神经递质是从哪里来的。它们就好像本来就在那里，我们只是研究它们的作用。但你猜神经递质是在哪里制造的？你的肠道。你的肠道会产生大量调节你情绪的神经递质，具体来说，大约占人体血清素的95%。基本上，这就是我们的“快乐荷尔蒙”。
This feel-good hormone is actually made in the gut by a specific kind of cell called enterochromaphn cells. I'm going to say it again, enterchromycin cells, which basically secrete and produce serotonin whilst they are in the gastrointestinal tract. Your gut microbes also play a really vital role in producing dopamine is another one. Gaba is another one, which you've probably heard about. before they're all very crucial for mood stability, for pleasure, motivation, and anxiety regulation. So if your gut microbiome is imbalanced, neurotransmitter production can suffer. And that's what's directly impacting your mood. The third and final component in the axis is, of course, the gut microbiome, which we've already
这种快乐荷尔蒙实际上是由肠道中的一种特殊细胞——肠嗜铬细胞制造的。我再说一遍，肠嗜铬细胞，它们在胃肠道内时会分泌和产生血清素。你的肠道微生物在产生多巴胺的过程中也扮演着非常关键的角色，多巴胺是另一种神经递质。GABA是另一种你可能听说过的物质。在它们之前，这些物质对情绪稳定、快乐、动力和焦虑调节都至关重要。因此，如果你的肠道微生态失衡，神经递质的产生就会受损。这就是直接影响你情绪的原因。轴系中的第三个也是最后一个成分，当然就是我们已经提到过的肠道微生态。
kind of mentioned. You may associate like the microbiome with things like kombcha, things like yogurt, probiotics, It's always mentioned in marketing for those kind of products. Basically, the way to describe it is that your gut microbiome is like a bustling metropolis. It's like a big city of trillions of bacteria and fungi and other microorganism in your intestines. People always worry about bacteria and they think that it's like this terrible thing. That's why we use hand sanitizer. That's why we need to wash our hands, whatever.
你可能会把微生态与康普茶、酸奶、益生菌等事物联系起来，这些产品的营销中总是会提到它们。基本上，如果用一种方式来形容，你的肠道微生态就像一个熙熙攘攘的大都市。它就像你肠道里由数万亿细菌、真菌和其他微生物组成的大城市。人们总是担心细菌，认为这是件可怕的事情。这就是为什么我们要用免洗洗手液，这就是为什么我们要洗手，诸如此类。
bacteria is actually very important for our survival as humans. And we have millions, if not billions of different types of bacteria in our body at any given time, including in our microbiome. And that's why the microbiome is called the second brain, because it's these microbes that actively communicate with our central nervous system. They produce various compounds as well, including short chain fatty acids. you cannot live and exist without these acids. And they also are one of the only products that can cross out the blood-brain barrier
细菌对人类的生存其实非常重要。在我们的身体里，包括在我们的微生物群系中，在任何给定时间都有数百万甚至数十亿种不同类型的细菌。这就是为什么微生物群系被称为“第二大脑”，因为正是这些微生物在积极地与我们的中枢神经系统进行交流。它们还会产生各种化合物，包括短链脂肪酸。没有这些脂肪酸，你将无法生存和生活。它们也是少数能够穿过血脑屏障的产品之一
to directly influence brain functioning and to directly help with inflammation in the brain as well. A lot of very long words, very complicated words, but when we talk about gut health, I just basically want you to know we're not just talking about food. We're not saying candy makes me feel bad, and that's just because of what's in it. It's because of the interaction it has with our gut. This is actually a really foundational pillar of mental well-being, not the only pillar, but a very foundational one. And knowing about the gut brain link can actually fundamentally shift how you approach meals.
从而直接影响大脑功能，并直接帮助缓解大脑炎症。有很多非常长的词，非常复杂的词，但当我们谈论肠道健康时，我其实只是想让你知道，我们谈论的不仅仅是食物。我们并不是说糖果让我感觉不好，仅仅是因为它里面有什么成分。而是因为它与我们的肠道产生了互动。这实际上是心理健康的一个非常基础的支柱，虽然不是唯一的支柱，但却是一个非常基础的支柱。了解肠道与大脑的联系，实际上可以从根本上改变你对待饮食的方式。
And it's about feeding your mood as well as your hunger. So let's explore maybe some sense. specific components of things to put on your mood menu? What are some of those foods to really lean into and to really consume more of from the perspective of providing your brain with the optimal power to support the gut brain access? One of the most powerful sources of fuel for your brain health is complex carbohydrates, those that are found in whole grains like oats, brown rice, in legumes and also in most fruits and vegetables. Unlike really simple sugars, carbs that are complex provide a really steady release of glucose. Glucose is the brain's primary energy source.
这不仅是为了填饱肚子，也是为了滋养你的情绪。所以让我们来探索一些具体的成分，看看应该把什么放进情绪菜单里？从为你的大脑提供支持肠道大脑轴的最佳能量的角度来看，有哪些食物是你真正应该倾向于多吃一些的？对你的大脑健康最强大的燃料来源之一是复合碳水化合物，它们存在于全谷物中，如燕麦、糙米、豆类以及大多数水果和蔬菜中。与非常简单的糖类不同，复合碳水化合物能提供稳定释放的葡萄糖。葡萄糖是大脑的主要能量来源。
So if you have a long lasting source of this, it helps prevent blood sugar spikes and crashes that can make us really irritable, make you really tired, make you really anxious. Also because they're rich in fiber that also, again, is beneficial. for our gut bacteria because it acts as a prebiotic. Prebiotics and probiotics, I think we should actually just take a hot moment and give them a dedicated shout out in this episode because they are some of your biggest allies in maintaining a really optimal, stable, healthy gut brain relationship. Probiotics are like, they are live bacteria.
因此，如果你有一个持久的能量来源，它就有助于防止血糖飙升和骤降，因为血糖剧烈波动会让我们变得非常暴躁、疲惫和焦虑。此外，因为它们富含纤维，这同样对我们的肠道细菌非常有益，因为它们可以充当益生元。益生元和益生菌，我觉得我们真的应该花点时间在这期节目中向它们致敬，因为它们是你在维持一个非常优化、稳定、健康的肠道大脑关系时最伟大的盟友。益生菌就像是活的细菌。
It's live bacteria that is found in fermented foods like yogurt, kimchi, sauerkraut, kombucha, they actively replenish and diversify your gut microbiome directly supporting your health. So think of it kind of like watering a plant, watering a plant, fertilizing a plant, this is what probiotics are doing. Then prebiotics, specific types of dietary fibers that also feed your gut bacteria. It's found in things like garlic, in onion, leeks, asparagus, unright bananas. you need that as well to thrive. You need a prebiotic, you need a probiotic,
它是存在于发酵食品中的活细菌，如酸奶、泡菜、酸菜、康普茶，它们能积极补充和多样化你的肠道微生态，直接支持你的健康。所以这就有点像给植物浇水，给植物施肥，这就是益生菌在做的事情。然后是益生元，这是一种特殊类型的膳食纤维，也能喂养你的肠道细菌。它存在于大蒜、洋葱、韭菜、芦笋、未成熟的香蕉等食物中。你也需要这些来茁壮成长。你需要益生元，你需要益生菌，
but you can also, or often, always find them in whole foods. I feel like they're often sold to us in a tablet form. You don't always need that. You can get it very easily from a lot of natural sources. We also have omega-3 fatty acids. These are essential for brain structure connectivity and neuroprotection against inflammation. If you don't have omega-3 fatty acids,
但你也可以、或者通常、总能在全食物中找到它们。我觉得它们经常以药片的形式向我们出售。你并不总是需要这些。你可以从许多天然来源中非常轻松地获取它们。我们还有欧米伽-3脂肪酸。这些对于大脑结构、连接以及针对炎症的神经保护至关重要。如果你没有欧米伽-3脂肪酸，
a myelin sheaf on your neurons, basically, on the axon, is going to not be able to replenish itself as easily, meaning that the connectivity between different neurons gets kind of frazzled because the message kind of gets lost along the way. So omega-3 fatty acids are found in things like salmon, sardines, chia seeds, walnuts, flax seeds, also super foundational to brain cell function. 2023 study published in the Journal of Personalized Medicine looked at a sample of 165 patients suffering from mild to moderate depression. Participants were kind of randomized.
基本上，神经元上（轴突上）的髓鞘将无法那么容易地自我补充，这意味着不同神经元之间的连接会变得有些零乱，因为信息在传递过程中丢失了。因此，欧米伽-3脂肪酸存在于三文鱼、沙丁鱼、奇亚籽、核桃、亚麻籽等食物中，对大脑细胞功能也超级基础。2023年发表在《个性化医学杂志》上的一项研究观察了165名患有轻度至中度抑郁症的患者样本。参与者被随机分组。
They either received an amygic three supplement, an antidepressant or a combination of both. Participants who took both the antidepressant and the omega-3 tablet showed a significantly higher improvement in depressive symptoms compared to those who just, just took either the supplement or either the antidepressant alone. Basically, it's not about only choosing one thing. That's a really important thing from this study that I think we can take away. Choosing one thing is obviously better than choosing nothing, but it's when we combine these different health interventions.
他们要么接受了欧米伽-3补充剂，要么接受了抗抑郁药，要么两者结合。同时服用抗抑郁药和欧米伽-3药片的参与者，与那些仅仅服用补充剂或仅仅服用抗抑郁药的人相比，抑郁症状有了显著更高的改善。基本上，这并不是说只能选择一件事。这是我们可以从这项研究中带走的非常重要的一点。选择一件事显然比什么都不选要好，但只有当我们把这些不同的健康干预措施结合起来时……
It's when we combine modern medicine and the ancient medicine of our food. Okay, this next thing, I'm going to sound like such a gym bro, but you've got to lean into your proteins as well. They are very crucial for our brain health. I feel like protein is having such a moment at the moment, things like chicken, eggs, tofu, lentils, beans. Turkey, you guys know what protein sources are. But the reason they're so vital is because protein is broken down into amino acids, which are the literal building blocks for your body's neurotransmitters. For example, tryptophan is an amino acid found in almost every single protein. it is a direct precursor to the creation of serotonin in your gut.
正是当我们把现代医学与我们食物的古老医学结合起来时。好了，接下来这一项，听起来我可能很像个健身房里的老哥，但你也必须重视你的蛋白质。它们对我们的大脑健康至关重要。我觉得蛋白质现在正处于一个非常火热的时期，比如鸡肉、鸡蛋、豆腐、扁豆、豆类。火鸡，你们都知道蛋白质的来源是什么。但它们之所以如此至关重要，是因为蛋白质被分解成氨基酸，而氨基酸就是你身体神经递质的字面构件。例如，色氨酸是一种几乎在每一种单一蛋白质中都能找到的氨基酸。它是你在肠道中产生血清素的直接前体。
You literally cannot make serotonin without tryptophan. So having that adequate protein intake really rigorously supports stable mood and cognitive function. If you're someone like, if you're a vegetarian, people are always talking about protein in terms of iron and in terms of energy levels. But you also need it to be happy. You need it so that your mood can properly stay. it's also the essential micronutrients, which I feel like don't get enough attention, but are very, very vital for the biochemical reactions going on in our brain, things like
没有色氨酸，你简直无法制造血清素。因此，摄入充足的蛋白质确实能够极大地支持稳定的情绪和认知功能。如果你是一个素食主义者，人们总是在铁质和能量水平方面谈论蛋白质。但你为了保持快乐也需要它。你需要它来让你的情绪保持正常。它也是必不可少的微量营养素，我觉得这些微量营养素没有得到足够的关注，但对我们大脑中进行的生化反应非常、非常重要，比如
B vitamins, vitamin D, often called the sunshine vitamin, which can reduce inflammation in the brain, support brain development, support neurotransmission. Without vitamin D, people sometimes suffer from what we know as the winter blues, not just because it's depressing when it's dark outside all the time, which is like a natural consequence of that. But it's a lot of also because there may be a serious vitamin deficiency. I think someone was telling me the other day that in the UK, like the NHS or like some health body, like recommended that everyone be taking a vitamin D supplement. I may be totally off the mark here, but that is how crucial it is. Magnesium as well. I take magnesium supplements for sleep. It is like the one supplement I truly
B族维生素、维生素D（通常被称为阳光维生素），它可以减少大脑炎症、支持大脑发育、支持神经传递。没有维生素D，人们有时会遭受我们所知的“冬季忧郁”，这不仅是因为外面天黑时会让人感到沮丧，这是其中的自然结果。但很大程度上也是因为可能存在严重的维生素缺乏。我记得前几天有人告诉我，在英国，NHS（国民保健制度）或某个健康机构建议每个人都服用维生素D补充剂。我可能完全记错了，但这正是它的至关重要之处。还有镁。我服用镁补充剂来帮助睡眠。这是我真正
swear by. I swear by it. When I started, I started. taking it, I've never slept better and I've never looked back. It is incredible. And also the final one for your brain health is zinc, which is basically the one ingredient we need for synaptic plasticity. It helps our brains adapt. It helps them connect. It helps them learn. This sounds overwhelming. I totally get you. I feel like I'm sitting in a science or a health class and a teacher is at a whiteboard, like screaming out, I don't know, like the functions of different vitamins. to me and I have to write them down on like a cue card. But when I first started learning about this stuff, I also was like, I have no idea what I'm doing. I have no idea how I'm going to
深信不疑的唯一一种补充剂。我坚信不疑。当我开始服用时，我从未睡得这么好过，也从未后悔过。这真是不可思议。最后一种对大脑健康至关重要的大脑营养素是锌，这基本上是我们实现突触可塑性所需的一种成分。它帮助我们的大脑适应。它帮助它们连接。它帮助它们学习。这听起来让人不知所措。我完全理解你。我觉得自己就像坐在科学或健康课上，老师在白板前大喊着，我不知道，比如各种维生素的功能，而我必须把它们写在小卡片上。但当我刚开始了解这些东西的时候，我也觉得自己完全不知道自己在做什么。我不知道该如何
remember all this, no idea what the perfect balance is going to be. I really did think like I need to completely overhaul my diet. Like I need to completely change everything. But it's actually a lot less complicated than you think. You probably are also, unless you're eating processed food for every single meal, you are probably already hitting the majority of these things. It's just about fine-tuning things and it's just about coming back to these core pillars and just reminding ourselves about why they are so important. You just, basically, you just have to find the balance that works for you because good food, even if it's not the best for you, is also a source of community. it's also a source of connection and pleasure. It can be a hobby. Yes, there is some science behind it that is very, very important and very crucial. The science isn't the only thing that matters. And I don't want that to get lost in all the scientific terms and all the definitions. So we are going to talk about balance. We're going to talk about how to integrate a better mixture of ingredients and things with nutritional value without losing joy.
记住所有这些，不知道完美的平衡会是什么样子。我真的以为我需要彻底改造我的饮食。就像我需要彻底改变一切一样。但实际上它比你想的要简单得多。除非你每顿饭都吃加工食品，否则你可能已经摄入了其中大部分的营养。这只是关于微调事情，只是关于回归这些核心柱石，并提醒自己为什么它们如此重要。你只需要基本上找到适合你的平衡，因为好的食物，即使对你不是最好的，也是社区的来源。它也是联系和快乐的来源。它可以是一种爱好。是的，背后有一些科学依据，这些依据非常、非常重要、非常关键。但科学并不是唯一重要的事情。我不希望这一点在所有的科学术语和定义中迷失。所以我们要谈论平衡。我们要谈论如何在不失去乐趣的情况下，整合更好的营养成分和食物混合比例。
And also the dangers in vilifying certain foods because every single food, unless you are allergic to it, does have a place in our overall diet. So we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. Hey, it's Gemma and I have something really special to share. I'm hosting my first ever virtual live video podcast, not a pre-recorded episode, not a highlight reel, but a real time face-to-face moment where we get to connect. laugh, reflect, and honestly just kind of be in it together, no matter where you are in the world. If you've ever hit play on an episode of the psychology of your 20s or mantra and thought, I really wish I could just talk to Gemma about this right now. This is your chance.
还要谈论妖魔化某些食物的危险，因为每一种食物，除非你对它过敏，在我们的整体饮食中都有它的地位。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。嘿，我是杰玛（Gemma），我有一些非常特别的事情要分享。我要主持我的第一场虚拟实时视频播客，不是预先录制的节目，也不是精彩集锦，而是一个实时的、面对面的时刻，我们可以一起连接、欢笑、反思，老实说，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，我们都能陪伴彼此。如果你曾在收听某一期《你二十岁的心理学》或《Mantra》时想过：“我真的很希望现在就能和杰玛谈谈这件事。”这就是你的机会。
We're diving into the messy, beautiful chaos of your 20s, your 30s of life and beyond. And yes, you get to be right there with me. There's a live chat so we can talk in real time. And afterwards, I'm hosting a private VIP party, my inner circle, we would call it, where I'll be answering your questions and getting even more personal. It's happening August 12th at 7pm Pacific Time or August 13th at 12pm if you're on Sydney or Australia. So mark your calendar, tell your friends, grab your ticket now at pave.com. I can't wait to see you there.
我们将深入探讨你二十岁、三十岁生活以及更远未来的混乱而美丽的美好混乱。是的，你完全可以和我在一起。这里有实时聊天，我们可以实时交流。随后，我将主持一个私密的VIP派对，我们可以称之为我的核心圈子，我将在那里回答你的问题，并进行更私密的交流。活动将于太平洋时间8月12日下午7点举行，如果你在澳大利亚悉尼，则为8月13日下午12点。所以请在日历上作好标记，告诉你的朋友，现在就在pave.com抢票吧。我迫不及待地想在那里见到你们。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app,
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用程序上，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
苹果播客，或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备谈论可卡因，但确实，确实，字面意思。但为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的心理健康领域经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的有
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们甚至不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的比赛。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你认为在地球上做一个好人很重要。你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能够纯粹地去做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed
加入我卡尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于一场父权丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会
revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
暴露出她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。这就引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你在某些地方篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
还有另外两名经历过同样事情的男士：格雷戈·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When it comes down to the psychology of food, people always want to know what is the best diet to be on. What should I be doing? I kind of hate the word diet because it kind of suggests like a fad crash and burnout change that isn't sustainable. So let's say food lifestyle. What food lifestyle is the best emulate? We did our research. We looked far and wide and let me tell you the consensus. time and time again is that the Mediterranean diet is the one that stands out and is also importantly the one that is least restrictive compared to things like keto or whatever else you're thinking of. The Mediterranean diet emphasizes whole unprocessed foods, plenty of fruit,
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。说到食物的心理学，人们总是想知道最好的饮食是什么。我应该怎么做？我其实有点讨厌“饮食”（diet）这个词，因为它听起来像是一种不可持续的、一时的狂热、崩溃和精疲力竭的变化。所以，我们换个说法，叫饮食生活方式。哪种饮食生活方式最值得模仿？我们做了研究。我们广泛搜寻，让我告诉你们大家的共识：一次又一次的共识是，地中海饮食是最突出的，而且同样重要的是，与生酮饮食或其他你脑海中的饮食相比，它是限制最少的。地中海饮食强调全食物、未加工食品，大量的蔬菜、
vegetables, legumes, nuts, seeds, olive oil, fish, poultry, a little bit of red meat, also like a little bit of added sugar. Basically, think foods from Greece, think Italy, think Spain, including the desserts, including the tasty treats, including the pastors and the pizzas and the big feasts and you are in the right area. This diet is the one that delivers a full spectrum of brain supportive nutrients and it's really great not just for you physically but for you mentally. For example, a 2009 study from researchers at the University of Navarra looked at the dietary patterns of over 10,000 university students, 10,000, or over a period of four years.
水果、豆类、坚果、种子、橄榄油、鱼类、禽肉、少量的红肉，还有少量的添加糖。基本上，想想希腊的食物，想想意大利，想想西班牙，包括甜点、美味的点心、面食、比萨饼和丰盛的节日大餐，你就找对方向了。这种饮食能提供全方位的支持大脑的营养，它不仅对你的身体极好，对你的心理也大有裨益。例如，纳瓦拉大学（University of Navarra）的研究人员在2009年进行的一项研究调查了10,000多名大学生（10,000名）在四年时间里的饮食模式。
And what they found is that students who most closely stuck to a Mediterranean diet pattern had a 42% reduced risk of developing depression. It's not just a collection of healthy foods. It is a synergistic way of eating that can really nourish your brain and your mood. I think also beyond just making certain dietary choices and food choices, it's also about being more connected to our food as a whole and noticing instead of ignoring when you have a certain reaction or a mood shift after a certain meal. Do like your own test. If you're unsure whether this is right for you, whether this food lifestyle is right for you,
他们发现，最严格遵守地中海饮食模式的学生，患抑郁症的风险降低了42%。它不仅仅是健康食品的组合。这是一种协同的饮食方式，能够真正滋养你的大脑和情绪。我认为，除了做出特定的饮食和食物选择之外，更重要的是要与我们的食物建立更紧密的联系，去注意而不是忽视在吃完某种特定食物后，你是否有某种反应或情绪的转变。就像做你自己的测试一样。如果你不确定这是否适合你，这种饮食生活方式是否适合你，
have a Mediterranean-based meal or try to eat in a Mediterranean manner for a day, then eat how you normally would for the next day and then try something completely different and just run your own experiment on yourself. Was there a change? And if there is, surely if it's a positive change, that's something you want to continue to do. If you have the opportunity to feel less crap, surely that's the avenue that you want to take.
吃一顿地中海式的餐食，或者尝试以地中海的方式吃一天，然后第二天照常饮食，接着尝试完全不同的东西，在你自己身上做一个实验。有变化吗？如果有的话，当然，如果这是一个积极的变化，这正是你想继续做的事情。如果你有机会感觉不那么糟糕，这肯定是你想要选择的途径。
I feel like people can say all that they want. People can make recommendations. I can make recommendations. And yet, if it doesn't work for you, it doesn't work for you. So if you're unsure, try it out of it. on yourself, just see how it shifts your mood, see how it shifts your comfort levels, your energy levels, and then you can base your own behaviours based on the results of how you've conducted this on yourself. Now, we've talked a lot about how food affects our mood and which
我觉得人们可以想说什么就说什么。人们可以提出建议。我可以提出建议。然而，如果它对你不管用，那就是不管用。所以如果你不确定，就在自己身上试一试，看看它如何改变你的情绪，看看它如何改变你的舒适度、能量水平，然后你就可以根据自己在自己身上进行测试的结果来调整你自己的行为。现在，我们讨论了很多关于食物如何影响我们的情绪以及哪些
foods kind of do that best, but this is bidirectional. So how does mood affect our food choices? we've all, I think, found ourselves reaching for a specific food when we are stressed, when we are sad, when we are bored, when we are overwhelmed, not primarily because we're physically hungry, but because we are seeking comfort or distraction. This is emotional eating. It serves as a coping mechanism or a learned response where food becomes something that offers, I don't know, I guess emotional comfort and it becomes a stand-in for more adapt. adaptive ways of processing difficult emotions.
食物效果最好，但这是双向的。那么情绪又是如何影响我们的食物选择的呢？我想我们都发现过自己在感到压力、悲伤、无聊、不堪重负时，会去寻找某种特定的食物，这主要不是因为我们生理上饿了，而是因为我们在寻求安慰或分散注意力。这就是情绪性饮食。它是一种应对机制或习得的反应，食物变成了一种能提供——我不知道，我想是情感安慰的东西，它成了处理困难情感的更具适应性方法的替代品。
On a deeper level, it actually seems that our brains and our bodies crave certain foods more based on our emotional state. For example, when we're stressed, studies have shown we have an increased appetite for sugary and fatty foods, probably because these are easier for our body to convert into energy, which of course it needs more of when it's under stress. Chocolate in particular is like the one food our brain really, wants us to eat more of, possibly because it's got fat, it's got sugar, it's delicious, it's high in calories. And again, under stress, our brain requires, I think about 12% more
从更深层次来看，实际上我们的思维和身体似乎更根据我们的情绪状态来渴望某些食物。例如，研究表明，当我们在压力下时，我们对含糖和高脂肪食物的食欲会增加，这可能是因为这些食物更容易被我们的身体转化为能量，而身体在承受压力时显然需要更多能量。尤其是巧克力，是我们的大脑真正希望我们多吃的一种食物，可能是因为它含有脂肪、糖分、美味且热量高。同样，在压力下，我们的大脑需要的能量大约比平时多12%。
energy than normal. Something that's high in fat and high in sugar, high in glucose, is a great source of that. When our mood, it is really low and really sad, we're also more drawn to carbs as well. There was this research from 2012, 2012, that basically said things like pizza, potatoes, pasta, they're all comfort foods and they do actually kind of improve our mood, but only for a second and they can lead to sugar spikes. They can lead to glucose spikes, which make us more irritated or more tired. And the problem is, is that that can become a cycle. And it's this weird question that a lot of people in like the nutritional psychiatry space have, is that is it the food affecting the mood or is it the mood affecting the food?
比平时多。高脂肪、高糖、高葡萄糖的食物是获取这些能量的绝佳来源。当我们的情绪非常低落和悲伤时，我们也会更被碳水化合物吸引。2012年的一项研究（2012年）基本上指出，像披萨、土豆、意大利面这些都是舒适食物，它们确实能在一定程度上改善我们的情绪，但仅仅是一瞬间，而且它们会导致血糖飙升。它们会导致葡萄糖飙升，这会让我们更加烦躁或更加疲劳。问题在于，这可能会演变成一种恶性循环。营养精神病学领域的很多人都有这样一个奇怪的问题：到底是食物在影响情绪，还是情绪在影响食物？
And it's kind of like a chicken and an egg problem. If you're saying that someone's diet is contributing to their depression, but their depression is contributing to their eating choices, which is contributing to their depression, like, firstly, where do you intercept in that place? And also, how do you know where that started? Was it that the mental health disorder already existed? Or was it that the diet came first?
这有点像先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题。如果你说某人的饮食导致了他们的抑郁，但他们的抑郁又导致了他们的饮食选择，而这又反过来导致了他们的抑郁，那么首先，你该在哪个环节进行干预？其次，你怎么知道这一切是从哪里开始的？是心理健康问题已经存在，还是饮食问题先出现？
So it's important not just to draw a meat, conclusions from from this research and suggest that it's saying yes if i eat processed food if i eat sugar i am going to be depressed or i am going to be anxious because it is again bidirectional there's also a science as to why we feel drawn to specific foods when we want comfort and why each of us kind of has a really nice personal preference for our favorite meal and what we want on a rainy day and what we want on our birthdays and what we want when we're going through a breakup and it's driven by a combination of factors. Firstly, obviously, we really love things that are high sugar, high fat content, but we also really like satisfying textures, so creamy or crunchy foods,
因此，重要的是不要从这项研究中草率得出结论，并暗示它是在说：是的，如果我吃加工食品，如果我吃糖，我就会抑郁，或者我会焦虑，因为这同样是双向的。为什么我们在寻求安慰时会被特定的食物吸引，为什么我们每个人对最喜欢的食物都有很好的个人偏好，以及我们在雨天想吃什么、生日想吃什么、经历分手时想吃什么，这背后也有科学依据，是由多种因素共同驱动的。首先，很显然，我们真的很喜欢高糖、高脂肪含量的食物，但我们也真的很喜欢令人满足的口感，所以奶油状或酥脆的食物
typically are those that show up more in comfort food items, and also foods that have a strong association with positive past memories, particularly, you know, your grandma's apple pie, your dad's spaghetti bowling nays. They did this research, I think, I don't remember the exact year, but they did this research that basically said that the comfort food we had as children typically ends up being the same comfort food we have as an adult, which I think is quite beautiful. A lot of the food that we eat that we really enjoy is often deeply tied to positive memories from our past. These conditions kind of associations mean that simply, you know, the sight, the smell, even the thought of these foods can evoke feelings of security and love and happiness
通常是那些更多出现在舒适食物中的食物，还有那些与过去积极记忆有着强烈关联的食物，尤其是，你知道的，你奶奶的苹果派、你爸爸的肉酱面。他们做过这项研究，我想，我不记得具体年份了，但他们做过这项研究，基本上表明我们在童年时期吃过的舒适食物，通常最终会成为我们成年后吃的舒适食物，我觉得这相当美妙。我们吃的很多真正喜欢的食物，往往与我们过去的积极记忆紧密相连。这些条件反射式的关联意味着，仅仅是（你知道的）这些食物的视觉、气味，甚至只是想到它们，就能唤起安全感、爱和快乐，
and they act as really powerful emotional anchors. And this is when it's important to acknowledge that food enjoyment, the happiness that is brought from food, isn't just limited to healthy items or those high in a specific nutritional value. There is a lot of happiness and joy and legitimate pleasure to be found in foods that technically might be described as indulgent or unhealthy. And it would be short-sided to ignore those foods and say that someone, you could have someone who eats like the cleanest that you have ever seen, but actually maybe less healthy in terms of their mental health than someone who eats completely clean, but then also really enjoys eating like their mom's carbunara or really loves to indulge in like chocolate cake, I don't know, once a week, twice a week, because that brings them happiness. Sometimes food can be nourishing not just because of nutritional value is basically what I'm trying to say.
它们充当了非常强大的情感锚点。在这个时候，重要的是要承认，享受食物所带来的快乐并不仅仅局限于健康的物品或那些具有特定营养价值的食物。在那些技术上可能被描述为纵容或不健康的食物中，可以找到大量的幸福、快乐和合法的愉悦。如果忽视这些食物，并声称某人——你可能会遇到一个饮食极为清淡、你所见过最干净的人，但实际上在心理健康方面，他可能不如一个饮食完全清淡、但也真的很喜欢吃妈妈做的卡宴奶油意面（carbunara）或者真的喜欢一周放纵自己吃一次或两次巧克力蛋糕（我不知道）的人健康，因为那能给他们带来快乐。我想表达的基本上是，有时食物之所以能滋养我们，不仅仅是因为营养价值，
It can be nourishing because of the memories attached to it, but also because of like the company that you're in when you're eating it. It has the power to nourish the body and the mind and the soul. That's why it's such a beautiful, powerful kind of medicine, I think. At this point, I do think, you know, we can't go any further without saying whilst the food we eat is important, it is incredibly dangerous to say, suggest or to swing too far the other way and attribute everything about our mood or our mental health solely to diet and therefore feel like if we ever touch anything with artificial sugar or anything that is processed, you know, our brain is doomed. Food is medicine, but it's not just medicine and it's not the only medicine. And if we believe that it is, I think we risk really
它之所以能滋养我们，还因为附着在食物上的记忆，以及你进食时的陪伴。它有滋养身体、心灵和灵魂的力量。这就是为什么我认为它是一种如此美丽、强大的“药物”。在这一点上，我认为（你知道的），在我们继续探讨之前，虽然我们吃的食物很重要，但如果走得太极端，把我们情绪或心理健康的一切都归咎于饮食，并因此觉得如果我们接触了任何含有人造糖或加工食品的东西（你知道的），我们的大脑就彻底完了，这种想法是极其危险的。食物是药，但它不仅仅是药，它也不是唯一的药。如果我们认为它是唯一的药，我想我们就有风险去
overlooking complex underlying health issues that demand professional medical intervention and not just dietary change. I'll say, I think I eat very, very healthy. I eat mainly whole foods. I still have OCD and I still have depression. And I take my supplements. Those things didn't, like, aren't going to cure me because this is a chronic illness that I have. And I wouldn't want anyone to take what I'm saying here and say, well, obviously that means that anyone who has a mental health condition could change it and they're choosing not to. If their diet is in their power, which again, it sometimes isn't always, well, then what's their excuse? If someone is genuinely suffering and is told, you know, just eat clean and you'll feel better when they're actually grappling with a severe
忽视了需要专业医疗干预而不仅仅是饮食改变的复杂的潜在健康问题。我想说，我觉得我吃得非常非常健康。我主要吃全食物。但我仍然有强迫症（OCD），我仍然有抑郁症。我吃着补充剂。这些东西并没有、也不可能治愈我，因为我患有的是慢性疾病。我可不希望任何人断章取义我在这里所说的话，然后说：“很明显，这意味着任何有心理健康状况的人都可以改变它，但他们选择不这样做。”如果他们的饮食掌握在他们自己手中（当然，正如我所说，有时并不总是在他们手中），那他们的借口又是什么呢？如果一个真正遭受痛苦的人被告知（你知道的）“只要吃得干净，你就会感觉好点”，而他们实际上正在与严重的
depressive episode or an undiagnosed chronic illness, it's very harmful. And this oversimplification can lead to, I think, significant delays in receiving appropriate care, prolonged suffering, and it can potentially even worse than the conditions trajectory and also someone's trust in the medical system. Imagine experiencing, you know, debilitating fatigue and mood swings, and all you're told repeatedly is just to eat more greens. Cut out all sugar. And then you do that, but nothing changes.
抑郁发作或未被诊断的慢性疾病作斗争，这会造成极大的伤害。这种过度简化会导致（我认为）获得适当护理的显著延迟、长期的痛苦，甚至可能恶化病情的发展轨迹，以及患者对医疗系统的信任。想象一下，经历着（你知道的）使人衰弱的疲劳和情绪波动，而你被反复告知的全部内容就是多吃绿叶蔬菜。戒掉所有糖分。然后你照做了，但什么都没有改变。
Then, A, sometimes you're going to have that experience with, you know, a medical professional doesn't even believe that you're doing those things. So you feel dismissed because they are so sure that diet will change things for you and then when it doesn't. Well, you must be the factor that has gone wrong in that equation. B, you can feel hopeless that you've done what was asked of you and it didn't help. So there's no future hope for you to do anything else. And C, you can also cut too much out and end up with malnutrition or a whole other series of problems. It kind of reminds me of one of my friends who she was diagnosed with chronic fatigue a few years back,
那么，第一，有时你会遇到这样的经历：医疗专业人员甚至不相信你在做这些事情。所以你会感到被解雇（被忽视），因为他们如此确信饮食会为你改变一切，而当它没有改变时。好吧，在这道方程式中出问题的肯定是你自己。第二，你可能会感到绝望，因为你做了要求你做的事情，但它并没有帮助。所以你对做任何其他事情都没有未来的希望。第三，你可能也会切除（戒掉）太多东西，最终导致营养不良或其他一系列问题。这让我想起我的一个朋友，几年前她被诊断出患有慢性疲劳综合征，
and I'm sure she doesn't mind me talking about it here. But she started to go to therapy to be able to deal with the emotional weight of it all. All the therapists seem to be able to talk about whether or not she was taking her vitamins. Like literally every session, not let's talk about the huge weight of this condition and how it's impacting you and how you feel like you're behind and you're missing out on your 20s, not, you know, how does this impact your relationships, your social life? It was just like, have you taken your vitamins? Are you putting in like proactive steps?
我确信她不介意我在这里谈论这件事。但她开始去接受心理治疗，以便能够应对这一切带来的情感负担。所有的治疗师似乎都只讨论她是否在服用维生素。简直是每一次治疗都是如此，而不是来谈谈这种病症的沉重负担，以及它是如何影响你的，让你觉得你落后了、错过了你二十多岁的时光；不是（你知道的）这如何影响你的关系、你的社交生活。而只是像：“你吃维生素了吗？你有没有采取积极主动的措施？”
And it was like, she was and they weren't helping. And she would actually just like come away from every session feeling a lot of guilt and a lot of shame. This feeling of being unheard of having your suffering minimized, like I said, it can deeply erode your trust in the medical system. And it can leave people feeling really, really isolated and really hopeless. And if we over-attribute everything to diet, this is going to happen more. Also, we have to be careful about talking about good versus bad foods when we talk about the psychology of food and how it affects our mood. Even when an approach with the best intentions,
结果就是，她照做了，但并没有什么帮助。而且她实际上每次治疗结束时都会感到极大的内疚和羞耻。这种不被倾听、痛苦被最小化的感觉，就像我说的，会严重侵蚀你对医疗系统的信任。这会让人们感到非常非常孤立和绝望。如果我们把一切都过度归咎于饮食，这种情况就会更多地发生。此外，当我们讨论食物心理学及其如何影响我们的情绪时，我们必须小心谈论“好”与“坏”的食物。即使是以最好的意愿去接近，
labelling foods as good or bad can quickly slide into a very problematic, psychologically confusing, psychologically damaging arena where we are attaching morality to inanimate items. When certain foods are deemed as bad or dirty and others grouped as good, we inadvertently start moralizing our eating habits, pure versus dirty, good versus bad. This isn't just about nutritional science anymore, it's about right and wrong. The food you eat reflects your moral character. It reflects how sinful you are. your virtue, like moral decisions, and that can really damage our psychological relationship with food.
将食物贴上“好”或“坏”的标签，很容易滑向一个非常成问题的、心理上令人困惑的、心理上有破坏性的领域，我们将道德强加给了没有生命的物品。当某些食物被视为“坏”或“脏”，而其他食物被归为“好”时，我们就会无意中开始将我们的饮食习惯道德化：纯洁与肮脏，好与坏。这不再仅仅是营养科学的问题，而是关于对与错。你吃的食物反映了你的道德品质。它反映了你的罪孽深重，你的美德，就像道德决策一样，这真的会损害我们与食物的心理关系。
And it can be really judgmental, really, really judgmental. It also might trigger avoidance of certain foods or of certain social events or spaces where those foods are present, which means that, yeah, you're going to suffer, even if you're eating all these amazing whole foods that are good for your brain and you're eating the quote unquote good clean, pure foods, your mental health could still suffer because you're missing out on the richness of life in other areas. And you're restricting. But particularly like insidious consequence of these restrictions can include progressively more disorder eating, such as orthorexia nervosa. Orthorexia, it's not yet a formal diagnosis in the DSM-5, but it is a
这可能真的带有批判性，非常、非常具有批判性。它还可能引发对某些食物的回避，或者对存在这些食物的某些社交活动或场所的回避，这意味着，是的，你将会受苦，即使你吃的所有这些对大脑有益的惊人全食物，你吃的是所谓的健康、干净、纯净的食物，你的心理健康仍然会受到影响，因为你在其他领域错过了丰富的生活。而且你在克制。但这种克制的一个特别隐蔽的后果可能包括逐渐加重的饮食失调症，例如神经性贪食症或健康饮食强迫症（orthorexia nervosa）。健康饮食强迫症，它还不是《精神疾病诊断与统计手册第五版》（DSM-5）中的正式诊断，但它是一个
proposed eating disorder that is characterized by unhealthy, obsessive, preoccupation with healthy or pure eating. And often I was reading this account from someone who works in eating disorder wards in the UK, she says a lot of people who have anorexia nervosa or bulimia nervosa end up developing orthorexia nervosa as they like slowly exit that previous disorder because orthorexia is kind of easier to disguise and more socially acceptable. It's just replacing one type of restriction for another, but because we've attached all these moral and ideas to what kind of foods we should eat and we shouldn't eat, sometimes people
提议中的进食障碍，其特征是对健康或纯净饮食的不健康、强迫性的过度关注。通常我读过英国进食障碍病房里某位工作人员的自述，她说很多患有神经性 anorexia（神经性厌食症）或神经性 bulimia（神经性贪食症）的人，在慢慢摆脱之前的失调症时，最终会发展出神经性健康饮食强迫症，因为健康饮食强迫症更容易伪装，也更容易被社会接受。这只是用一种限制代替了另一种限制，但因为我们把所有这些道德观念都附加在我们应该吃什么和不应该吃什么食物上，有时人们
don't notice that being obsessed with clean eating is just as sometimes problematic as being obsessed with not eating at all or being obsessed with food in any kind of psychologically damaging way. So if diet advice is absolutely everywhere, and sometimes even unhelpful or harmful, how do we effectively deal with people who seemingly think they know what's best for us when it comes to our diet? It can feel incredibly invalidating, it can feel intrusive, it can frankly feel pretty annoying if you haven't invited commentary on it. Now, if you're at your doctor's office and you're saying, I want to make changes or can you make suggestions for areas where I may have nutritional deficits or may
没有注意到沉迷于健康饮食，有时和沉迷于根本不进食，或者以任何在心理上有破坏性的方式沉迷于食物一样成问题。因此，如果饮食建议无处不在，有时甚至没有帮助或有害，当我们面对那些自以为在饮食方面最了解我们的人时，我们该如何有效地处理呢？这会让人感到极度无效，感到具有侵略性，坦白说，如果你没有主动征求意见，这会让人感到非常烦恼。现在，如果你在医生的办公室里说：“我想做出改变，或者你能对我有营养缺乏的领域或可能
need to increase the intake of certain things. Obviously, that's not going to be harmful. Not every mention of diet or food is going to harm every single person. We're talking about strangers, we're talking about family members, we're talking about friends who just kind of can't keep their mouth shut when it comes to what you're putting inside your body. When someone comments directly on what you're eating or takes like a bit of a superiority stance on how their diet is so much healthier than yours, it just, you've got to know that it comes from a place of insecurity and potentially over-monitoring from them. If they're commenting and trying to control what you're consuming, you can only imagine how much they're controlling and restricting
需要增加某些东西摄入量的领域提出建议吗？”显而易见，这不会是有害的。并不是每一次提到饮食或食物都会伤害到每一个人。我们说的是陌生人，我们说的是家人，我们说的是那些在涉及你吃进体内的东西时管不住自己嘴的朋友。当有人直接评论你吃的东西，或者对他们的饮食比你健康得多表现出一种优越感时，你必须明白，这源于他们的不安全感以及他们潜在的过度监控。如果他们评论并试图控制你的消费，你只能想象他们是如何控制和限制
their own diet. Because honestly, who really cares enough to outwardly comment on what other people's eating behaviours reflect unless they are the ones who are consumed by it in their personal lives. Providing someone with unsolicited advice is everything about them, about their beliefs about food, about their consumption of diet culture, about what others have maybe said to them in the past, and very little to do with you. Because also they don't have the full picture. We are all so incredibly unique. We all have different deficiencies and nutrition levels and underlying health differences or intolerances, underlying relationships with food either positive or negative.
他们自己的饮食的。因为说实话，除非是在他们的个人生活中被饮食所吞噬的人，否则谁会真正关心到去公开评论其他人的饮食行为所反映出的东西呢？给别人提供未经请求的建议，完全是关于他们自己、关于他们对食物的信仰、关于他们对饮食文化的消费、关于别人过去可能对他们说过的话，而与你关系不大。因为他们也没有掌握全貌。我们每个人都是如此的独一无二。我们都有不同的营养缺乏症和营养水平、潜在的健康差异或不耐受，以及或正面或负面的潜在食物关系。
It is no one's business to give you advice on something you never asked for, especially not something as emotionally charged as food. If someone offers you this kind of interjection, it might be worth responding something like, that's an interesting perspective. For me, personally, I'm just focused on what makes my body feel good these days. Or saying something like, oh, I know you mean well,
对你从未要求过的事情提供建议，特别是像食物这样充满情感色彩的事情，是关乎他人屁事。如果有人提出这种干涉，或许可以这样回应：“这是一个有趣的观点。就我个人而言，我最近只关注什么能让我的身体感觉良好。”或者说类似这样的话：“哦，我知道你是好意，
but comments about eating on my body aren't particularly helpful for me. So could we change the topic? You don't owe anyone an elaborate explanation on your food choices. Your body, your choices, your health journey. The most powerful tool is often to just really set a clear, kind, but firm boundary that allows you to reclaim autonomy over your personal health narrative. Same goes for commentary on the internet. So how can we translate all of this knowledge into actionable steps?
但关于我身体饮食的评论对我来说并不是特别有帮助。所以我们能换个话题吗？”你不需要向任何人详细解释你的食物选择。你的身体，你的选择，你的健康之旅。最强大的工具往往是真正设定一个清晰、友善但坚定的界限，让你重新夺回对个人健康叙事的自主权。网络上的评论也是如此。那么，我们如何将所有这些知识转化为可行的步骤呢？
How do we continue to build a relationship with food that truly supports our mental well-being from our gut to our culture to our personal choices. I think it's about moving away from rigid rules more towards a place of intuition, respect, information, education and just like holistic balance. The more you know about this, starting with resources like this podcast, starting with books from health professionals, starting with reading the academic research yourself, the more you're able to make informed choices, the more you actually just notice your own body as well. That's like your biggest source of data. That's your biggest, the best research that you can kind of perform is on yourself. I think a great way to embrace this
我们如何继续建立一种真正支持我们心理健康的食物关系，从我们的肠道到我们的文化，再到我们的个人选择。我认为这是要摆脱僵化的规则，更多地转向直觉、尊重、信息、教育以及整体平衡。你对这方面的了解越多，从像这个播客这样的资源开始，从健康专业人士的书籍开始，从自己阅读学术研究开始，你就越能做出明智的选择，你就越能真正注意到你自己的身体。那是你最大的数据来源。那是你可以进行的最好、最大规模的研究，就是对你自己进行研究。我认为拥抱这一点的一个好方法
is through mindful eating, through just slowing down, not restricting, not cutting anything out, just paying attention to your body's signals of hunger, signals of fullness, signals of energy, signals of sluggishness, savor the textures, savor the smells, savor the taste, put away distractions like your phone or your TV. Do not eat, watch in YouTube. I'm sorry, but it is such an easy way to disconnect you from the natural feelings and relationship we have with our food.
是通过正念饮食（mindful eating），通过慢下来，不限制，不切除任何东西，只是关注你身体的饥饿信号、饱腹信号、精力信号、迟钝信号，品味质地，品味气味，品味味道，收起像手机或电视这样的干扰物。不要一边吃一边看YouTube。我很抱歉，但这是一种极其简单的方式，会让你与我们和食物之间的自然感觉和关系脱节。
Same with eating in front of the TV. I've been trying so hard to do this. I also have this practice that I've been trying recently where every time I take the first bite of my food, I try and imagine what it would taste like. Like, I try and imagine this is the first ever food I've tried. Like, this is the first time I'm experiencing any of these new flavors, any of these new sensations. Like, I'm an alien who is trying their first ever, like, human earth meal.
在电视前吃饭也是如此。我一直非常努力地这样做。我最近也在尝试这样一种练习：每次我吃第一口食物时，我都试着想象它会是什么味道。比如，我试着想象这是我尝试过的第一种食物。就像这是我第一次体验这些新风味、这些新感觉。就像我是一个外星人，正在尝试他人生的第一顿人类地球餐。
And it kind of like, it's strange. It's fun, which is also always good to bring. some fun into anything in your life. And it really reconnects me with like my body's wisdom and like it's natural enjoyment and curiosity around food and what it wants to enjoy, what it wants to eat, what it wants to fuel me and what it doesn't. Also, let's just really try to consciously change the language we use to describe food. I need to do this as well. I'm sure I've slipped up during this episode, but just actively identifying question any things that you call good versus versus bad, pure versus evil, clean versus dirty, any of the labels that you've assigned to food,
这感觉有点……很奇怪。很有趣，在你的生活中给任何事情带点乐趣总是好的。它让我重新与我身体的智慧连接起来，与它对食物的自然享受和好奇心连接起来，去感受它想享受什么，它想吃什么，什么能为我提供能量，什么不能。另外，让我们真心实意地尝试有意识地改变我们用来描述食物的语言。我也需要这样做。我确信我在这一集里也说漏嘴了，但要积极地识别和质疑你称之为“好”与“坏”、“纯洁”与“邪恶”、“干净”与“肮脏”的任何事情，以及你分配给食物的任何标签，
all foods can fit into a balanced diet. Releasing those moral judgments about eating will also significantly reduce feelings of guilt and shame and really foster a more peaceful, sustainable relationship with food. They say the easiest way to let something control you is to try not to think about it. and to try and avoid it. So if you're constantly trying to avoid a food you deem as bad or, or, I don't know, dirty or not clean, like, it's going to constantly be popping up in your mind. And it's actually going to control you more compared to if you just freely let it be part of your life and just enjoy it every now and again. Okay, we are going to take another short break,
所有食物都可以融入均衡的饮食中。释放对饮食的道德判断，也将显著减少内疚和羞耻感，并真正培养出一种更加平和、可持续的食物关系。俗话说，让某事控制你的最简单方法，就是试着不去想它，并试图避开它。所以，如果你一直在试图避开你认为是不好的、或者我不知道是“脏的”或“不干净”的食物，它就会不断地在你的脑海中浮现。与你如果只是自由地让它成为你生活的一部分、偶尔享受一下相比，它实际上会更加入侵地控制你。好了，我们要进行另一次短暂的休息，
but when we return, we have some very interesting listener questions, including whether men and women should approach their diets slash food lifestyles differently, whether there are certain foods that make our mood worse and where alcohol kind of plays a role in this equation. So stay with us for more after this short break. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
但当我们回来时，我们将回答一些非常有趣的听众问题，包括男人和女性是否应该以不同的方式对待他们的饮食/食物生活方式，是否有某些食物会使我们的情绪更糟糕，以及酒精在这个方程式中扮演什么角色。所以在短暂休息之后，请继续收听我们的节目。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上惊恐的许多问题其实都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是英文的 TWO%。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，大谈80年代的可卡因（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病（AIDS）摆在台面上了。谢谢你把话说完。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《硬核学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是——
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid?
特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你认为在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地去成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《硬核学习》（Learn the Hard Way）中，就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开免费的 iHeart Radio 应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的诉讼战，旨在证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini.
你在某某事件中两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士：
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷戈·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Welcome back. We have three really great listener questions today to finish off our episode on the psychology of food and how it affects our mood. Questions that cover topics and cover kind of avenues of this topic that we have not even discussed yet. So this is a whole new, whole new level to this topic. Beginning with this first question from Isabel in Vancouver, there is so much noise online about the harms of ultra-processed food, food dyes, sodas, etc. And I was wondering, is there actually science to whether this food makes our mental health worse? Or is it just classic online fear mongering. I know you'll get to the bottom of it. Love the podcast. Thank you.
欢迎回来。今天我们有三个非常棒的听众问题，来为我们关于食物心理学及其如何影响我们情绪的一集节目画上句号。这些问题涵盖了我们甚至尚未讨论过的主题和方向。所以这是这个主题的一个全新层面。首先是来自温哥华的伊莎贝尔（Isabel）的第一个问题：网上有很多关于超加工食品、食用色素、苏打水等危害的噪音。我想知道，这种食物是否真的会让我们的心理健康恶化，这背后有科学依据吗？还是说这只是一种典型的网络贩卖焦虑？我知道你会弄清真相的。非常喜欢这个播客。谢谢。
Thank you, Isabel. Let's break this question down, like you said, based on the evidence, based on the science. Firstly, when we're talking ultra-processed food, think packaged candy, instant noodles, fast food, these have been linked in multiple studies to poor mental health outcomes. We're just going to start from there. Now, we know that correlation doesn't mean causation. And so to blame mental health issues squarely on ultra-processed foods is probably not correct, but there have been a few studies which do say it increases the risk, including a 22 study published in public health nutrition that found that people who consumed the highest amounts of ultra-processed foods had a significantly higher rate of experiencing depression and anxiety symptoms. They kind of linked that mechanism
谢谢你，伊莎贝尔。正如你所说，让我们根据证据、根据科学来剖析这个问题。首先，当我们谈论超加工食品时，想想包装糖果、方便面、快餐，多项研究已将这些与不良的心理健康结果联系在一起。我们先从这里开始。现在，我们知道相关性并不等于因果关系。因此，将心理健康问题完全归咎于超加工食品可能并不正确，但确实有一些研究表明它会增加风险，其中包括2000年发表在《公共卫生营养》（Public Health Nutrition）上的一项研究，该研究发现，消费最多超加工食品的人群，经历抑郁和焦虑症状的比率明显更高。他们将这种机制与
to blood sugar spikes and crashes, to chronic inflammation, and of course, disruptions in the gut microbiome. That's what they were saying. The food was, that was what it was responsible for creating, which then created the depression or the anxiety. So it's a mediating factor. Basically, you know, our guts are these very ancient systems and they aren't meant to process strange chemicals that don't exist in the real world. And so when our guts, you know, encounter these chemicals, they kind of don't really know what to do with it and they can become a little bit confused. that is what causes like the uproar in the stomach and that is what causes what this study suggested as the issues later on with psychological symptoms and psychological arousal. Another study from
血糖的飙升与骤降、慢性炎症以及当然还有肠道微生物群的失调联系起来。这就是他们所说的。食物就是造成这种情况的原因，进而导致了抑郁或焦虑。所以这是一个中介因素。基本上，（你知道的）我们的肠道是非常古老的系统，它们并不打算去加工那些现实世界中不存在的奇怪化学物质。因此，当我们的肠道（你知道的）遇到这些化学物质时，它们其实并不太清楚该如何处理，而且可能会变得有点困惑。这也就是引起胃部骚动的原因，并且这正是该研究表明随后导致心理症状和心理唤醒问题的原因。来自
23, this study I think is more rigorous. It had about 23,000 participants and it did also find that a diet high and ultra-processed food elevated psychological distress in participants, which as a result is a precursor to depression. So again, it's not a direct factor, it's a mediating or moderating factor. Primarily because of what they said was increased inflammation in the brain, but it's also hard to rule out other factors. Like, is it because people who are living in poverty objectively, you know, don't have as much money for whole foods and for fresh fruits and vegetables? So they rely more on ultra-processed foods, but also because they're living in poverty, they're also more likely to have higher rates of
2023年的另一项研究，这项研究我认为更加严谨。它大约有23,000名参与者，它也确实发现高超加工食品的饮食会加剧参与者的心理痛苦，而这反过来又是抑郁症的前兆。所以再次强调，这不是直接因素，而是一个中介或调节因素。主要是因为他们所说的大脑炎症增加，但也很难排除其他因素。比如，是不是因为生活在贫困中的人客观上（你知道的）没有那么多钱买全食物和新鲜水果蔬菜？所以他们更多地依赖超加工食品，但也因为他们生活在贫困中，他们也更有可能拥有更高比率的
mental health disorders. So it's not. the food that's causing the depression, it's the poverty that's creating both the depression and the food choices. Or is it because people with depression find it easier to rely on ultra-processed food because it requires less effort when everything else in their life feels very hard to accomplish? So again, it's not that the food is creating the depression or the food is creating the anxiety, but other factors. I also think with all the stuff online that we hear about ultra-processed foods. Obviously, it's important to consider the science and the fact that there is evidence to suggest that ultra-processed food doesn't exactly help us. But at what level does it start
心理健康障碍。所以，不是食物导致了抑郁，而是贫困同时造成了抑郁和食物选择。或者是因为患有抑郁症的人发现更容易依赖超加工食品，因为当他们生活中的其他一切都感觉很难完成时，它需要的努力更少。所以再次强调，并不是食物造成了抑郁或食物造成了焦虑，而是其他因素。我也认为，对于我们在网上听到的关于超加工食品的种种言论。显然，考虑科学以及存在表明超加工食品对我们确实没有帮助的证据是很重要的，但它在什么程度上开始（戛然而止）
to harm us? That's another question that researchers haven't really been able to answer. Is it any processed food? Is it once a week? Is it twice a week? The fact that there isn't like a specific level upon which ultra-processed food and its contribution to your diet becomes dangerous and people haven't been able to target that, shows that this is still very much based on so many other individual factors. So my advice would be to consult a dietitian if you think ultra-processed food is an issue for you, consult a registered dietitian as well. But otherwise, take what you read online with a large pinch of salt, especially if people are only talking about their own experience, because as we can see, it is going to differ from person to person, and ask people their sources,
来伤害我们？这是研究人员一直未能真正回答的另一个问题。是任何加工食品吗？是一周一次吗？还是一周两次？事实上，并没有一个具体的标准，表明超加工食品及其对你饮食的贡献在什么程度时会变得危险，人们一直无法确定这一点，这表明这仍然在很大程度上取决于许多其他个人因素。因此，我的建议是，如果你认为超加工食品对你是个问题，请咨询营养师，同时也咨询注册营养师。但在其他方面，对待你在网上看到的内容要持保留态度，特别是如果人们只谈论他们自己的经历，因为正如我们所看到的，情况会因人而异，并询问他们的信息来源，
if they're going to make large-scale claims, make sure they have evidence to back it up and investigate the evidence as well and just do what's best for you. You know, a candy bar isn't going to kill you unless you choke on the wrapper. A can of Coke Zero or Sprite or whatever it is isn't going to kill you.
如果他们要做出宏大的声明，请确保他们有证据来支持，并且也要调查这些证据，做最适合你的事。你知道的，一块糖果不会害死你，除非你被包装纸噎住。一罐零度可乐、雪碧或其他什么东西也不会害死你。
I know it's going to sound so cliche, but again, it's all about balance. Next question comes from David. If our brains and stomachs are connected, surely when we get drunk, Digesting alcohol the next morning also contributes to us feeling bad. What's the impact of booze in this situation? You know what, David?
我知道这听起来是个陈词滥调，但再说一次，一切都在于平衡。下一个问题来自大卫。如果我们的大脑和胃是相连的，那么当我们喝醉时，第二天早上的酒精消化也会导致我们感觉不舒服。在这种情况下，酒精的影响是什么？你知道吗，大卫？
Great question. I had honestly never thought about this. I kind of always just thought of alcohol as influencing the mind only, but I went searching for an explanation for you. So alcohol, as you may know, increases intestinal permeability. Basically, you might know it as leaky gut. Leaky gut is what allows toxins and inflammatory molecules to enter the bloodstream and to kind of trigger a systemic inflammatory response.
这是一个很好的问题。说实话，我以前从未想过这一点。我过去总是认为酒精只影响大脑，但我为你去寻找了一个解释。所以，如你所知，酒精会增加肠道通透性。基本上，你可能知道它叫肠漏。肠漏会让毒素和炎症分子进入血液，并引发全身性炎症反应。
This inflammation is what affects the brain via the gut brain access. And it can worsen symptoms like anxiety, like fatigue and brain fog. Studies have also shown that alcohol can alter the gut microbiome and damages the gut lining. alcohol is also quite acidic. So when it sits in the stomach, not that it can damage it, but it is a little bit harder to process. Think about how our body process is something that's acidic.
这种炎症正是通过肠脑轴影响大脑的因素。它会加重焦虑、疲劳和脑雾等症状。研究还表明，酒精会改变肠道微生物群并损害肠道内壁。酒精也相当具有酸性。因此，当它停留在胃里时，倒不是说会损害胃，但处理起来确实有点困难。想想我们的身体是如何处理酸性物质的。
It has to find another and equally kind of counterbalancing, like chemical with acidity in it or acid or bile. And so it can kind of just lead to an imbalance of a lot of different things in your stomach. It's probably one of the major reasons why hangover is. feel so physically and mentally brutal. I feel like also TMI, but if you get really drunk, like you can kind of notice that in terms of your bowel movements, movements like the next day. So there's obviously something going on. And if you're throwing up, if you're feeling really
它必须找到另一种同样能起到平衡作用的化学物质，其中含有酸性物质、酸或胆汁。因此，这可能会导致你胃里的许多不同事物失去平衡。这可能是为什么宿醉在身体和精神上都如此痛苦的主要原因之一。我觉得这也算是过度分享，但如果你喝得大醉，比如你可以从第二天的排便情况中注意到这一点。所以显然有什么事情正在发生。如果你在呕吐，如果你真的感觉
ill the next morning, if you're nauseous, like all of those are signals from your gut to your brain, like something is wrong. And so if you can consciously tell something is wrong, that means your brain is seriously like in over and drive up there trying to control whatever's going on in your stomach. So a paper I did read though said, this is not pleasant and it's not comfortable in the short term. It might contribute to why you feel terrible the day after you drink. But it does take a lot of drinking for this to become severe and for alcohol to truly damage your intestinal tract and your stomach and your gut. you have to be engaging in some pretty significant alcohol consumption over a number of years
第二天早上很不舒服，如果你在恶心，所有这些都是你的肠道向大脑发出的信号，表明出了问题。因此，如果你能清醒地意识到出了问题，那就意味着你的大脑正在严重超负荷运转，试图控制你胃里发生的一切。不过，我读过的一篇论文指出，这并不令人愉快，短期内也不舒服。这可能是你喝酒后第二天感觉糟糕的原因之一。但这需要大量的饮酒才会变得严重，并让酒精真正损害你的肠道和胃。你必须在好几年里进行相当大量的饮酒
to really mess up the gut brain access, but it does still happen. And especially with the amount of like binge drinking that goes on in our 20s, if you're worried about it, trust your intuition there and maybe pull back. But yeah, great question. And we have one final question actually from an anonymous listener. I feel like different food affects me at different times based on where I am in my menstrual cycle, especially since I have pretty bad PMS. Is there any research on what foods to eat depending on which phase you're in? Just how to sneak this one in here? Because I feel like this is a really great example of a question that combines food, combines hormones and combines our mind and the brain. And the answer is
才会真正搞砸肠脑轴，但这种情况确实还会发生。特别是考虑到我们在20多岁时经常暴饮暴食，如果你担心这一点，相信你的直觉，也许应该收敛一点。但是的，这是一个很好的问题。事实上，我们还有一个来自匿名听众的最后问题。我觉得不同的食物在不同的时间对我有不同的影响，这取决于我处于月经周期的哪个阶段，尤其是因为我的经前综合症（PMS）相当严重。有没有关于根据你处于哪个阶段该吃什么食物的研究？只是想在这里顺便问一下这个问题，因为我觉得这是一个很好的例子，结合了食物、荷尔蒙以及我们的思想和大脑，而答案是
that yes, the foods you eat at different phases does impact how you're going to feel. This is where the concept of cycle-sinking with your food comes in. Some people do it with their exercise, but basically cycles thinking is where you change your daily routines and your daily behaviors based on kind of which phase you're in because often our moods and how our body feels can be a great indicator of what our body actually needs from us in terms of fuel. In the menstrual phase when you're on your period, estrogen and progesterone at their lowest and that often leads to lower energy, fatigue, potential mood dips. That's why we really crave things like chocolate and fatty foods and sugary foods, as we said before, they have a natural comfort element to them.
是的，在不同阶段吃的食物确实会影响你的感觉。这就是饮食与周期同步（cycle-syncing）概念的由来。有些人将其用于锻炼，但基本上，周期同步是指你根据自己所处的阶段改变日常例行程序和行为，因为通常我们的情绪和身体的感觉可以很好地指示我们的身体在能量方面实际需要什么。在经期，当你处于月经期时，雌激素和孕激素处于最低水平，这通常会导致能量下降、疲劳以及潜在的情绪低落。这就是为什么我们真的渴望巧克力、高脂肪食物和高糖食物的原因，正如我们之前所说，它们具有天然的安慰作用。
But of course, because blood is also being lost around this time, our levels of iron are also depleted. So you want foods rich in iron, like red meat, lentils, spinach, they're really recommended. And also foods rich in magnesium can actually support muscle relaxation, reduce cramping. So think dark leafy greens and nuts, but also things that are high in natural sugar, so fructose, or just the occasional treat because it's going to make it feel a little bit easier and make it more enjoyable for you. As you move to the follicular phase after your period and until ovulation, estrogen slowly rises again, bringing with it increased mental clarity, you're in a better mood, probably feeling pretty sexy, feeling pretty, I don't
但当然，由于在这个时期也会流失血液，我们的铁水平也会耗尽。所以你会想要富含铁的食物，比如红肉、扁豆、菠菜，这些真的很推荐。此外，富含镁的食物实际上可以支持肌肉放松，减少经期痉挛。所以可以考虑深色绿叶蔬菜和坚果，还有富含天然糖分的食物，比如果糖，或者偶尔吃点甜食，因为这会让感觉轻松一点，让你更享受。当你进入排卵前卵泡期，即月经后到排卵期这段时间，雌激素缓慢上升，随之而来的是思维更加清晰，心情更好，可能感觉自己很有魅力，感觉自己很
know, feeling pretty romantic. Here your body is in need of lighter and vibrant. more vibrant foods. So broccoli, cauliflower, kale, berries, which can help with hormone regulation and metabolism. Also lean into your proteins, lean into your complex carbs. They're really key for supporting rising energy levels. For the ovulation phase when obviously estrogen and energy levels peak, it's really important to feed your body easily digestible foods like fresh fruit and vegetables. The key here is really colourful produce to help support. your cells and to support the growth of new cells as you finally move into your luteal phase where progesterone is dominant, estrogen dips. This is obviously the phase that is most
不知道，感觉挺浪漫的。在这里，你的身体需要更清淡、更有活力的食物。比如西兰花、花椰菜、羽衣甘蓝、浆果，这些有助于荷尔蒙调节和新陈代谢。同时，多吃蛋白质，多吃复合碳水化合物。它们是支持不断上升的能量水平的关键。对于排卵期，显然雌激素和能量水平达到顶峰，向身体提供易于消化的食物（如新鲜水果和蔬菜）真的很重要。这里的关键是色彩缤纷的农产品，以帮助支持你的细胞，并在你最终进入黄体期（孕激素占主导地位，雌激素下降）时支持新细胞的生长。这显然是与
commonly associated with PMS symptoms like mood swings, irritability, anxiety, fatigue. Within this phase, research shows us that you're really going to want something salty, you're really going want complex carbs, things like oats, things like sweet potatoes, things like dark chocolate. They are all recommended to help support the production of serotonin and prevent rapid sugar dips that could just make your irritability and just all those emotions that you're feeling worse. I think it's just really empowering to know how to work with our bodies and adapting our nutrition to our personal needs and what could nourish us without being restrictive. So as we finish up this episode, I just want to make it very clear.
经前综合症（PMS）症状（如情绪波动、易怒、焦虑、疲劳）最相关的阶段。在这个阶段，研究表明你真的会想吃点咸的，真的会想吃复合碳水化合物，比如燕麦、红薯、黑巧克力。这些都被推荐用来帮助支持血清素的产生，并防止血糖快速下降，因为那会加剧你的易怒感以及你所感受到的所有情绪。我认为，了解如何与我们的身体合作，根据我们的个人需求调整营养，并在不进行限制的情况下滋养我们，这真的赋予了我们力量。因此，在我们结束这一集时，我只想明确一点。
Food and mood are linked through the gut brain access. We know that. It's very complex. It is not the only thing going on. Our brain is also an organ that has things going on separate to the stomach that can impact the mental health issues that we're facing and the mood instabilities that are afflicting us. So if anyone ever says, you can change your entire brain and your whole life just with food, unless you have a severe allergy, that's probably not the case.
食物和情绪是通过肠脑轴联系在一起的。我们知道这一点。这非常复杂。这并不是唯一在起作用的事情。我们的大脑也是一个有独立于胃的事情发生的器官，这些事情会影响我们面临的心理健康问题以及困扰我们的情绪不稳定。所以，如果有人说你可以仅靠食物改变整个大脑和生活，除非你有严重的过敏症，否则情况可能并非如此。
Make sure that this is part of a very holistic and diverse nuanced perspective on this. Don't let people shame you for your food choices as much as we've had very in-depth discussion here. None of this is prescriptive. If it doesn't work for you, it doesn't work for you. And that doing what's best for you is always going to be better than any recommendation that someone might give you, that isn't individualized and isn't personalized. So just keep that in mind, but I do hope this episode at least gave you something to think about, gave you some more information.
确保这是对此事非常全面、多样且细致的观点的一部分。不要让别人因为你的食物选择而羞辱你，尽管我们在这里进行了深入的讨论。这些都不是清规戒律。如果它对你不管用，那就是不管用。做最适合你的事，永远比别人可能给出的任何非个性化、非定制的建议都要好。所以请记住这一点，但我确实希望这一集至少能给你一些启示，为你提供更多信息。
I want to thank Elizabeth Colbert, our research assistant for her contributions to this episode and all the papers and all the research that she looked into to make this as comprehensive as possible. If you did enjoy the episode, make sure to share it with a friend, share it online, on Instagram, I don't know, on LinkedIn, Pinterest, wherever you share. the things that have inspired you recently so that we can bring some new listeners to the show. Make sure you get your tickets for my virtual live show, which is happening next week. I literally cannot wait.
我要感谢我们的研究助理伊丽莎白·科尔伯特（Elizabeth Colbert）为本期节目做出的贡献，以及她为了让本期节目尽可能全面而查阅的所有论文和研究。如果你确实喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友分享，在网上分享，在Instagram上分享，我不知道，在领英（LinkedIn）、Pinterest上分享，或者在你最近受到启发的地方分享，这样我们就能为节目带来一些新的听众。请务必购买我将于下周举行的虚拟直播节目的门票。我简直迫不及待了。
I could meet as many of you as I possibly can in that virtual room. And so I hope to see as many of you there as possible. And ensure that you are following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want a summary of this episode, if you want to be able to contribute a listener question, or for whatever reason. If you've made it this far, I want you to leave a broccoli emoji down below. Actually, no, we did that one the other day. Guys, I'm losing track.
我希望能在这个虚拟房间里尽可能多地见到你们。所以我希望能在那里看到尽可能多的你们。请确保在Instagram上关注我，账号是That Psychology Podcast。如果你想要这一集的摘要，如果你想贡献一个听众的问题，或者由于某种原因。如果你已经听到了这里，我希望你在下方留下一个西兰花表情符号。其实不用，我们前几天刚用过那个。伙计们，我都记不清了。
What's another food that we talked about here? Leave a little dark chocolate emoji down below. I feel like dark chocolate was the star of this episode. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. Don't let anyone tell you what to eat or when to eat it, unless they are a very qualified doctor or a very qualified individual. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我们在这里讨论过的另一种食物是什么？在下方留下一个小黑巧克力表情符号。我觉得黑巧克力是这一集的明星。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。不要让任何人告诉你吃什么或什么时候吃，除非他们是极具资质的医生或极具资质的个人。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这是当自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健康和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会破茧成重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字2%（TWO%），在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个大日子。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way
84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这对于黑人来说更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》
with your favorite therapist and host, Keir Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability
与你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Keir Games）一起。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方真正都不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力
that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我对测试动了一次手脚。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
格雷格（Greg），一个同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉（Laura），斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是由人类制作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。